[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another
installment of harry potter theory in
today's video we're going to be
discussing albus dumbledore severus
snape and the half blood prince more
specifically i'm going to be discussing
what i expect to be quite a
controversial theory as it surrounds the
iconic albeit equally tragic death of
hogwarts head master albus dumbledore
let's set the scene with the passage
from chapter 27 the lightning struck
tower
snape said nothing but walked forwards
and pushed malfoy roughly out of the way
the three death eaters fell back without
a word even the werewolf seemed cowed a
snape gazed for a moment at dumbledore
and there was revulsion and hatred
etched in the harsh lines of his face
severus
please
snape raised his wand and pointed it
directly at dumbledore avada kedavra a
jet of green light shot from the end of
snape's wand and hit dumbledore squarely
in the chest harry's scream of horror
never left him silent and unmoving he
was forced to watch as dumbledore was
blasted into the air for a split second
he seemed to hang suspended beneath the
shining skull and then he fell slowly
backwards like a great ragdoll over the
battlements and out of sight the above
passage of course refers to dumbledore's
death at the hands of severus snape a
moment that shocked the wizarding world
to its core
dumbledore in some ways was a beacon of
hope for the good guys a powerful and a
wise old wizard that even voldemort
feared but when he was struck with
snapes of arakudavra that all changed
and in that moment harry felt more
helpless than ever dumbledore's death
was a big deal he was 115 years old and
had made a profound impact on the
wizarding world of the course of his
life his death also raised a lot of
questions how could the wise and
powerful dumbledore be defeated in such
a paltry manner surely if he had wanted
to survive he could have right well
today's theory is going to discuss why i
think the dumbledore may still very well
be alive
first let's take a look at why
dumbledore opted to die or at least
opted to appear to die
what it really boils down to is the
unbreakable vow that snape had made with
narcissa in this vow snape vowed to both
watch over draco as well as take action
on draco's part in the event that he was
unable and what was draco's assignment
kill albus dumbledore will you severus
watch over my son draco as he attempts
to fulfill the dark lord's wishes i will
said snape a thin tongue of brilliant
flame issued from the wand and wound its
way around their hands like a red-hot
wire
and will you to the best of your ability
protect him from harm
i will said snape by taking on the
responsibility of killing dumbledore in
the event that draco was unable it was
essentially saving draco but why you
might ask would snipe willingly enter
such a vow
well i've got a few ideas the obvious
answer here would be that dumbledore was
sick and going to die anyway and by
offering to kill him he was essentially
providing dumbledore with a less painful
way out however i'm of the impression
snape agreed to the vow because he never
intended on killing dumbledore at all
snape and dumbledore were both master
tacticians and accomplished oklahomans
masters of the mind so surely it isn't
unreasonable to assume that dumbledore's
death was simply orchestrated by them
with that said let's look at the facts
here dumbledore died as a direct result
of snape's killing curse or avada
kedavra snape simply pointed his wand
and stated the incantation
and following this dumbledore flew into
the air for a brief moment before
falling over the battlements and out of
sight the details that i want to hone in
on here are the spelled snape used as
well as the fall of dumbledore to kill
dumbledore snape uses avada kadavra an
unforgivable curse with a simple purpose
instantly kill your victim the spell
creates a blindingly intense green bolt
of light right before the victim simply
drops dead but what if snape didn't use
zavada kedavra at all from a very young
age snape was a magical prodigy a
talented student that went above and
beyond what was expected of him in
school his own copy of advanced potion
making which propelled harry through his
potions class contained notes that
improved upon the methods recommended by
the authors of such textbooks and he was
able to do this at a very young age
possessing snape's textbook was like
having cheat codes to potions lessons
but potion making advice wasn't all that
was inside there were spells as well
spells that harry had never seen before
most notably snape had invented the
spell sektum sempra a vicious dark curse
that acts like an invisible sword
causing lacerations hemorrhaging and
cuts upon its target in short snape has
a demonstrated ability to invent create
his own spells so is it really out of
the question for him to have invented a
foe of alikadavra a spell that sounds
looks and feels so similar that only its
creator would be able to assess its
validity i don't think so perhaps this
version of avadikadavra still kills the
victim but only temporarily or maybe it
just paralyzes your body entirely giving
everyone the impression that you're dead
maybe it just does nothing and the
victim plays dead in the film adaptation
of the half blood prince snape savada
kadavra appears to contain an awful lot
of blue and strays somewhat away from
the green that we had become accustomed
to in previous films this could
potentially further suggest that the
avada cadaverous snape used wasn't
actually a vada kadavra at all but
instead a spell of his own creation the
alternative to this theory and one
that's more in line with the books is
that snape did genuinely use avada
kedavra hence producing the green light
mentioned in the books however if snape
were to have used avada kadavra on
dumbledore i'm of the impression that it
wouldn't have worked in order for a vada
kadavra or any unforgivable curse to
truly be effective you must truly loathe
that person
and if you don't then a less effective
version of the spell will be produced we
see this when harry tries to use the
cruciatus curse on bellatrix despite his
sheer anger he still wasn't able to use
the spell to its true effect yes snape
fired a killing blow at dumbledore but
because snape lacked the emotions
necessary to produce the spell in its
full capacity dumbledore was able to
survive but wait we still fell off the
tower didn't he well there are a few
ways for him to have survived the fall
the first possibility surrounds a spell
that we actually see dumbledore use in
an earlier film arresto momentum which
is used to slow the velocity of an
object i would imagine that in this
scenario dumbledore was either conscious
enough to cast the spell himself or it
was built into the spell snape had
created an alternative to oresto
momentum being used links back to
another theory of mine and that's that
dumbledore is in fact an unregistered
animagus we know for a fact that once
patronus form generally provides insight
into what one's animagus form would be
we also know that dumbledore's patronus
is a phoenix so i'm suggesting this
after being thrown over the battlements
dumbledore simply turned into his
phoenix animagus form flying away
everyone would have thought it was just
forks other plausible alternatives are
that he was able to operate caught by
his broom or saved by forks okay now
i've got another element to address his
body doesn't dumbledore have an entire
funeral if he survived then how can his
motionless corpse be reasonably
explained well i don't think it's
entirely impossible to deduce that snape
a potions expert could have created some
sort of concoction for dumbledore to
drink upon his safe landing a concoction
that would bewitch the mind ensnare the
senses and in a roundabout way put a
stopper in death it should also be
mentioned that dumbledore surviving
doesn't impact the plot that follows his
death before his death while still in
possession of the elder wand dumbledore
was disarmed by draco and it's been
proven that ownership can be gained
simply through disarming does not
necessarily require death therefore
dumbledore surviving does not disrupt
the path of ownership that the wonder
eventually follows as for snape and the
vow yes he agreed to carry out draco's
deed but it should also be mentioned
that there was no time limit on that
term
so there's certainly no reason that he
would have dropped dead simply from
casting a different spell on dumbledore
in that moment as for dumbledore's hand
i think the prodigious minds of snape
and dumbledore along with the help of
fox's tears could have figured out a
remedy what do you guys think could
dumbledore have survived far-fetched i
know but it's fun to come up with
theories like this particularly ones
that bring dumbledore back to us if i
miss something glaringly obvious in this
theory i hope not if you enjoy the
content please remember to like the
video and subscribe to the channel until
next time remember the things we lose
have a way of coming back to us in the
end if not always in the way we expect
[Music]
you